we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey hey here we are folks we might be
drunk we're back it's good to see you
sam you look great you like to be back
you look fit thank you i've never been
worse shape i got aids well your bad
shape is at least thin thank you
herniated disc right here baby
mri came back hd
that's what we're in but the chest hair
is popping out i've always wanted a
chest hair pop out too much no it's only
one bug
it's one button but just call me
armenian and get it over with will you
genocide
but no i think it's good i wish i my
girl's always like i wish she had a
little more chest there really ah oh she
lays it out there she's like give me two
more inches of dick some chest air and
an inch at height and i'm like all right
i get it
uh my girlfriend says a little less dick
and a little less hair oh
that's a good place to be uh no she i i
once had a girlfriend who said
she wanted me to shave my chest oh
i was like 20 i was like 21 so i did it
whoa yeah and it was like it was weird i
remember my brother was like what the
[ __ ] happened like he was judged me hard
uh it looks weird i mean my dad is the
hairiest guy on the planet and he shaved
one time and i was like i'm moving out
this is gross you're not a man it was
like you said you shaved your chest no
no he did i was like this is horrific it
like grossed me out as a young boy
seeing you know your hero this manly guy
bear i was like ah what are you trans
what's going on here it was a bummer
yeah that's rough damn yeah he's a hairy
guy huge package you know military yeah
forearms like giant full like popeye
scary dude you ever choke you
uh a few times from the he do the back
joke like get in that [ __ ] car and
you're like ah
don't hurt me down
and then i had that you know that dad
energy you know you you've had it with
your son you have died look at that look
at those forearms oh yeah he got that
joke in the sun yeah it was like the
bart simpson
well yeah dad uh do you ever have one of
these from your dad
that'll [ __ ] that i straight i got a
lot of wrist grabs oh my dad would never
hit me he would i got more of the
liberal parent
we're not mad we're disappointed oh that
hurts worse it hurts way worse i'd
rather hit me with a switch my mom would
cry be like this is horrible you know
but i get the wrist grab occasionally
nothing worse than the mom going you're
hurting him
you hear that you're like oh that's bad
that's a bad family
the only thing worse is if she yells and
you're hard
yeah my gal once i one time i had to
yell at a cabbie because he was like he
tried to i accidentally put a hundred
bucks in the tip on accident oh and he
was like sorry i can't help you and i
was like you better change that [ __ ]
thing and she was like that was so hot
you stood around i was like wow women
are [ __ ] weird what do you ladies
like
we have no idea what women want you're
choking him later the night she tells
you to choke her it's weird
yeah now i'm like getting ubers i'm like
yell at me i'm like trying to lie to him
in the text
i can get laid start [ __ ] please yeah
i'll give you five stars just call me
call me a weak man yeah i'll show you
what's what right right yeah i'll tip
you later
but yeah yeah no respect in my household
my dad choked me but only during sex i
got to tell you
there we go yeah my wife and i were
happy for 20 years then we met all right
no respect that's a great line rodney's
the best he's the best he's the king and
i think he's coming up on a
birthday
100 years
very exciting 100 years of rodney baby
yeah yeah very exciting wow that's crazy
jacob cohen real name yeah from queens
i'll tell you no respect as a kid my
mother she got morning sickness after i
was born
wait what is it i'm gonna blow it
uh my doctor said yeah you're unhealthy
he said i'm gonna get a second opinion
all right you're ugly too that's the
classic that's a classic perfect one
yeah
speaking of it he was uh
molested he said there was like a
neighborhood pedophile that would drive
around yeah he would drive around you
drive around the neighborhood
on the mouth and he would just like make
out with him every day yeah he would get
you know he'd be like get in the car
little boy and then he would [ __ ] with
him whatever but uh so when he was young
you got respect
[Music]
so that's what that aretha franklin song
is about i had no idea
but yeah
child porn speaking of kitty
nirvana kid 30 years old the little boy
swimming with the dong out in the pool
yeah suing as calling it child porn
is there it's art or child i thought it
was art it's a poster right well here's
the here's the rub if it is declare
child porn we all bought it i bought
that album weird to see here here's the
rub right before you talk about
yeah i rubbed one out to that poster
but did that mean that tower records had
kitty porn in there i guess so i guess
so yeah that isn't that crazy we all
bought child porn i'm a proprietor i saw
this ad though and he was in the pool
like doing a shoot for it so
oh he's looking for a little cash maybe
2.5 million is a lot of money and it's
like you want to talk about who had
problems it's like hard to sue the guy
curcumin killed himself it's like you
weren't more [ __ ] up than the guy
whose music it was good point good point
what i'm saying also you could spin it
to a positive like every girl you hook
up with you're at a bar like i'm the kid
and it's gotten bigger you know like
that's an inn baby
i was in the pool or even worse i'm a
kid
it's the same size oh god yeah that was
a tiny dong but they're all tiny at that
age oh no baby is a giant dog ah
did you hear about the kid who needed
surgery pull it up
wait wait wait we gotta get a drink yeah
i need a drink this is we didn't drink
this last week we opened the package
it's the argyle uh sparkling wine from
my buddy craig who came out to my shows
in portland this weekend hey he's my
camp counselor when i was a little kid
great guy and uh yeah it's i'm touched
that he sent us his package of wait
don't say camp counselor in touch to the
same stuff
yeah we're talking about kitty porn over
here are we going to get a big peter
north here is this just going to come
off
oh
mazel tov very exciting pop the cherry
there you go it's good sparkling rose i
i've never had this now rose is is a
little bit of a
housewife thing isn't it i feel like it
is are we how i mean it's during the day
this is all right yeah it's a summer
drink we've been drinking a lot of like
you know hard [ __ ] that's true we don't
have our guy here he got a he got
screwed by the taliban so uh we're damn
it i know they got him they got him yeah
because we're calling him the bear jew i
told you not to pull out
but yeah
they got him so uh thank you sir
he'll be back next we gotta wait for
sally to cheers here oh yeah
for some reason they always find
something
let's see we go all right
[Music]
that's really good that's refreshing
damn i wouldn't i'm not a big i don't
like rose but there's this good stuff
it's very good i think oh [ __ ]
wine is like uh tap dancing i can never
tell if it's good or bad
yeah true you can tell if it's bad
that's true looking up a kid's penis big
penis what do you want me to look up
what words
do you want this on your [ __ ] hard
drive no
but this it was a news story kid was
born with a huge dong it was a football
shape literally the size of a football
so it was like a deformity yeah throw
football in there that'll throw off the
government
michael vick michael dick all right hold
on but he uh he they so the mom goes
well obviously we gotta we gotta cut
this down so they still gave him eight
inches
wait wait wait watch why not how do you
cut down a penis well they you know what
do you call reduction breast reduction
dick reduction i didn't know you could
do a dick reduction yeah yeah that is
crazy you can reduce anything
jesus oh sorry my wallet's going off
what are you talking about i bought a uh
a tile look at this my wallet got stolen
a couple months back
so i bought this
tracking device that's smart yeah i
gotta get one of those tile check it out
send us a send us a free tile will ya
but it goes off every now and then
what do you got i needed wi-fi uh we
need the wi-fi pull that up on the uh
the arby's as a speaker
guess wifi this is when we hear the
sirens pulling up
jared from jared fogle's here everybody
man what a weird run
it's 11 401
is the password right now everyone else
now everyone's got that dude this is
[ __ ] good it's pretty good
i'm not a big sparkling i'm not a
champagne guy i gotta be honest it's
good for a celebration you have the
flute it's fun but i don't i don't if
i'm celebrating off scotch or like a
manhattan or something i don't
ah yeah i want a paper plane again
paper plane has taken over i mean
everyone's posting about it we haven't
talked about planes this much since 9
11. it's the biggest thing everybody's
posting about it i'm reposting
that thing took off i drank so many of
those call me amelia earhart because i
did not come back
talk about spirit
all right so uh man yeah i was in
portland all weekend
helium rocks man oh great club a great
town man that crowds are so good uh
went to the nike factory overrated
they go to the employee
store they just post and someone gives
you an access code hooked them up with
some free tickets in exchange hell yeah
yeah it was i got these yeah i got these
right here they're fun little air max 95
action yeah you got the air max we're
rocking them yeah it was fun i had a
good time i was sick as a dog that's the
thing that sucks when you're on the road
now every time you get like a headache
you're like covered yeah
am i out for five do i miss a road
weekend now because this [ __ ] brutal
yeah and i'll tell you the other thing
portland is the most portland [ __ ] is
i can look i'm like let me get tested to
make sure i'm not like spreading this to
people yeah and they're like nah no none
of our places offer that on short notice
i'm like i'm trying to help you i'm
trying to be a decent dude here trying
to not spread here
what what and i thought cover was like i
mean uh portland's like crunchy and like
super wokey i thought they'd be all over
that [ __ ] dude last time i was in
portland i did not have like my people
at the show it was years ago
remember i had that alligator dead baby
oh yeah i was working that joke out
there it was like eight minutes of
bombing every show i would be killing
and then i'd do that bit and it would
bomb every show and then i was like i
should drop it and luckily i was in
tampa the next weekend
and they ate that [ __ ] up like they were
the gator all right
[Laughter]
uh tampa does not give a [ __ ] and i
think it was a florida story right yeah
and they still loved it they still loved
it they
there it is
i know that kid pull it up
wait that's not it that's a different
one three penises that's three different
three penis mike damn hold up he's gonna
be polly though
yeah he can be bi gay and straight
each deck is a different thing yeah
exactly yeah everybody doesn't have
three hands
um but yeah portland i found that i used
to go there you know i've been going
there for years and
i would call them out for being crunchy
and everybody's like oh portland oh here
we go and they would go the opposite
they would be like yeah [ __ ] it
like let's let's let's get dirty it's
like you it's like salt lake city they
know their reputation yes so then they
come out and they're extra cool they get
overcompensated yeah then they're like
child rape bits and we're like all right
calm down
right right
yeah no i love poor i love that club i'm
there i think in november i can't wait
always always do well we do well in in
smart
uh
white cities
you know like
chicago well chicago's mixed but it's
like denver san fran
portland
phoenix austin i feel like a lot of
these are mixed all right i hope i want
to be mixed yeah but
i don't know are black people coming out
they're not vaccinated
is that is that offensive i'm just going
home 20 uh
27
of
young black people in new york are
vaccinated 27 percent that's not that
high that's what we're saying
you see the commercials now and it's
like every commercial about getting
vaccinated is like a young black guy he
was like i got it and it didn't kill me
and it's and you're just like
i see why you're doing it yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna be like hey it's safe but you
know right right well you know if it
works if any group's gonna be
distrustful with the government
i mean they've kind of earned it of
course of course tuskegee i hope
i hope they get vaccinated sure
but you know [ __ ] i don't know i mean
they can handle illness magic johnson
well he's the richest [ __ ] dude with
age ever
that's your example for a survivor
charlie sheen also rich
how's he doing is he still aids riddled
all right he was banging ports i
remember he had that moment of like
winning and tiger blood all that you
knew that wasn't going to last
that was rough yeah that went out
quicker
they had they were the topic
oh my god
he was [ __ ] porn
star he uh no he
i had the biggest crush on denise
richards when i was oh really i did i
did someone i can't say his name but i
did someone's radio show once and he was
like
rush limbaugh
[Laughter]
i i and i and he was like who are your
childhood crushes and i said uh denisha
richards he's like who else was like ah
like like jennifer love you it and we
went to break and he goes [ __ ] them both
whoa
and i was like all right wow
yeah i'll tell you i can't say his name
my name is god i want to blow this guy
that's second hand
i want to smell that secondhand maxim
magazine holy [ __ ] them both that isn't
i mean you believe him yeah oh wow pull
that down dude nope
sam's getting chubbed
whoo
that was the thing in new orleans uh for
a friend's birthday when they turned 18
strip clubs you'd go to strip clubs with
your friends when he turned 18
and they would bring the guy on stage
whose birthday it was and all the
strippers would dance on him and if he
got a boner he had to pay and if he
didn't you didn't have to pay it was
like this fun new orleans tradition so
they'd be like oh you got to pay up he's
hard we were all like yeah
it was a win either way you know he's
got to bring your gay friend just
tortured these strippers like it's been
45 minutes
we're dancing on this
guy um yeah portland is pretty cool man
i had a good time there for sure i like
i i respect uh those crowds we get our
crowds now so i know some people are
like
portland but now they're i think they're
pretty cool they're pretty cool they're
pretty and they've been through a lot
this this pandemic wildfires that
portland weather is like a dark cloud
and then the alternative is hell rising
i'm like this is a dark uh existence you
guys have
it's heroin it's shanghai it's crazy
they they there was protests there was
riots it got wild out there so i'm glad
they're doing okay yeah for oh man those
those riots in portland did not look uh
fun no no and here's some controversial
voodoo donuts overrated it's still good
though i mean it's a donut you can't go
you're not a donut guy i'm not a donut
guy but i'll eat a me and him go to the
donut pub it's great love the donut pub
underrated and also that's ambiance too
true true that is the little episode
yeah that was great but look it's just a
big donut with with [ __ ] froot loops
on it like that ain't that ain't uh i'm
gonna disagree here i'm gonna say voodoo
donuts i went there once years ago jeff
ross and i hit the one in austin uh-huh
and i think we went through twelve
donuts as it did what we went through
twelve donuts wow we just both were just
he he
had a bunch and then they recognized him
so they just kept giving him donuts oh
man well he went there the year before
with ralphie may and like what happened
but yeah that's not ingenuity that's an
innovative oh it's a it's got an
umbrella in it whoa
i'll tell you what works on a donut and
it's this may sound just like overkill
you ever have like bacon on a doughnut
the one a doughnut pub i never have that
one's [ __ ] good dude what give me
your top donuts ah well you're gonna
hate me i like cake
plain donut i think that's the best
donut i think this is all overkill let's
see the picture of the cake playing
donuts just the stamps means
old-fashioned old-fashioned okay yeah
great though no no i'm actually with you
on that i think an old-fashioned is a
classic for a reason i like it with a
coffee yes i'm with you
it's just enough sugar it's not the
glaze the glaze is dripping laser than
the powdered sugar yeah powdered is the
worst i like the homer simpson donut too
oh the pink the pink is the pink is
great pink and the steak yeah yeah the
old-fashioned is where it's at oh i love
it i'm getting ten of those oh they're
[ __ ] good so good where were you out
on krispy kreme it's all right
you know right it's fine
i'm just not i'll tell you what i like
in portland if i got my sweet tooth on
is uh salt and straw ice cream man i'm
more of an ice cream guy than a donut
same same what's salt and straw it's
like their famous ice cream place
oh okay incredi i mean i waited on the
line once to go there i wonder what the
line it's it's i don't know if it's just
it's crazy
all right i'll be there when i go there
i'll be at salt and straw it's legit
it's funny how they legalized all drugs
in portland you guys talking about ice
cream and donuts
cause it all it comes back to the
classics man yes oh it's an old
fashioned for a reason and if it's
portland it's gonna be a paper straw
all right which i don't think even help
right i don't know that was improving
that it's [ __ ] that was one turtle
photo that shows the power of marketing
and social media it was one turtle photo
and that did it
i want more of this it's pretty good
matt how was your how's your wrist doing
man i'm so glad you have finally asked
matt got really mad at me the other
night why because he told me got in a
biking accident and what did i say matt
so i'm telling him this harrowing story
about me falling off a rebel which you
shouldn't be driving to begin with man
it's dangerous i don't want you on those
oh it's fine i used to play baseball
so uh taxi cab cuts me off uh i fall i
wipe out i start chasing the cab driver
down i knock on his window and i make
him stop i'm telling the story and i
show him the injury and he looks at me
he's like ah yes you know i sat in
behind molly shannon on the plane right
here ah
i was like you didn't even hear my story
i said oh [ __ ] and then i said all right
it was basically you're saying oh i've
got a story too
your life doesn't matter i was tired i i
i it was that's not cool that i could be
there you did just get off first class
flight
behind molly
this is good shannon i love molly
shannon i wrote her a family when i was
a kid i wrote her a fan letter and she
and she signed it what i wrote to i
loved knight at the roxbury as a kid so
i wrote to molly shannon chris kattan
and will ferrell and chris conan and
molly shannon wrote back i think pharaoh
probably got too many he's a little busy
yeah
oh dude i love her i love her she's so
funny she's on white lotus she's she's a
killer man she's
beast i heard she uh
the rumor is this was on curb they said
she [ __ ] a guy so well that he had a
heart attack
why she's just wild in the sack that was
that's on curb
that's an episode though what they talk
about on curb yeah pull it up
what are you talking about that wasn't
up there there larry and
uh jeff are like oh she's great in bed i
hear she's wild
i think he knows her i think he was like
[ __ ] with her
did not kill two men
it's like a gerbil thing with your gear
it's out there it's a fun myth no she
dude i love her she's so funny i think
oh so funny so funny where has she been
she's just in that thing she dude she's
in a movie i forgot what it's called
look it up it's by the writer chris
kelly from snl where it's just i think
his real story where his mom died of
cancer she should have won an oscar oh
really she's that good in it man she's a
beast it's one of those roles where
you're like oh [ __ ] like you are a legit
actress you're not just a comedic like
it was a dramatic performance we were
like whoa
and uh
she i
one time schumer was having a party and
i'm with rachel feinstein we're both
running late to a foot to a seller's
spot and we're panicking we're like [ __ ]
we're gonna miss our spot as he's going
to kill us as a weekend
and uh oh boy molly's parties are hard
to leave hard to leave because there's
free booze fun crabs
molly shannon's in the elevator with us
and i think she just overheard us
panicking and she runs across the street
and we we just see her go i got you guys
a cab
i was like this is like the best person
what a night
i was at one of those parties the
schumer party and i was pretty drunk and
i'm walking around and i'm like
and like a dream like an angel it was i
saw marissa tomei dancing with her shoes
off like alone and i was like oh my
childhood crush and uh she was like you
want to meet her and i was like of
course and i went up and i was like hey
my cousin vinnie and she was like ah
yeah yeah you said my cousin
what the [ __ ] i didn't know what to say
i said seinfeld i was like i saw you
it's george i panicked you gotta play
you gotta pretend you don't know who
they are go marissa oh okay i'm mark
nice to meet you i've seen her naked i
couldn't contain myself where's she
naked in the restaurant yes and before
the devil knows you're dead oh she's
getting railed from behind sydney
lamette no is that him that was his last
one i think whoa
am i right sally picking it up that was
a good movie great movie i mean you get
[ __ ] philosomo hoffman in anything oh
there she is from brooklyn by the way
yeah she's beautiful and she still looks
great and
great actress obviously great actress
but uh
i mean dude
so you think i'd [ __ ] know what the
deer was wearing that was my horrible uh
my cousin vinnie one of the all-time
great comments great comedy doesn't get
brought up a lot by the way sydney lumet
so i just watched i just made my
girlfriend watch dog day afternoon she
fell asleep she was tired
she fell asleep for like 20 minutes so
she got the gist she felt in the middle
of 20 minutes i was still pretty upset
yeah it's amazing because oh it's i
think it holds up as one of the best
movies ever here's what blows my mind
about it is like
he's not only bi but he's paying for a
sex change and they're not like they're
not cheap about it
like i mean there's a couple cops
laughing which is just realistic yeah
like
i thought it was like pretty
tastefully done for a 70s movie yeah
about trans way ahead of the game and
it's also [ __ ] hilarious like when
john cazale [ __ ] legend by the way
killer five movies and they're all
classic all nominated for best picture
whoa
what a record dating meryl streep yes
whoa that's a power company yeah
amazing wow that was that was a rough
one the problem with that sex though is
uh if they fake it you believe it
because they're great actors
you know the orgasms were like was that
real i'll never know she's uh you know
she went to juilliard yeah he's so good
he could fake coming oh it's like wow
you're a good actor he brought props
no he uh dude the whole thing where he's
like we got to leave america where
should we go and he goes wyoming that's
one of my favorite things that's a great
that's a great moment god that movie's
good that's dude pacino can i give you
my wreck for this week so dog day
afternoon obviously classic we haven't
seen it you should see it but this is my
wreck and it's a little more off the
gridiron
sorry dude that seems like that's dude
the movie's amazing afternoon is
one of the best movies ever amazing
movie and it's the brooklyn scenes with
the kids where they're all watching it's
all great it's it's a it's a time
capsule for new york in the 70s killer
my favorite movies are movies that have
like everything where you're like
there's funny parts there's sad parts
yeah intense parts there's action
that's that's the reason he looks just
like pacino i know wow
wow it kind of looks like de niro too
yeah deniro could have your godfather 2
de niro could have played that
definitely mean streets de niro wow
72 failed bank robbery have you been to
the bank sally yeah i was in my old
neighborhood really yeah yeah it's right
near park slope oh my god how cool is
that yeah so you were probably a kid
when this happened yeah i didn't know
about it but yeah damn wait when were
you born
all right don't make him say martial all
right all right this is
dude uh
so here's my wreck and it's a lesser
because i got a pacino kick cause like
there's all right look here's the deal
pacino's been in some stinkers she's
also been to some of the best movies
ever so here's a lesser-known pacing
pacino movie from the 90s simone
jack and jill no
no here's my pick it's from the 90s it's
it's streaming on amazon
it's a michael mann film i haven't seen
it since i saw it in the theater wait a
minute are you going to say what i think
you're going to say
what
not here no not eat okay
i just said that did you say that out
loud i just said that no
the insider oh yeah oh i won best
picture that's not it didn't win best
picture i don't think it did nominated
didn't win the insider wait do i know
this movie it's like a big it's a fight
against like big tobacco basically
russell crowe pacino christopher plummer
it's [ __ ] amazing good kind of killer
dialogue i don't know it i saw it last
time i saw it was in the theaters i
remember being a kid when i saw it and
being like wow i was really locked by it
wow it's like two hours and 40 minutes
but it's like there's so many scenes
where you're like [ __ ] that was good
writing
wow i don't know i know the inside man
which uh that's a good movie that's good
i think a little overrated but it's good
but it's a fun heist movie yeah it's a
spike lee joint but uh owen's [ __ ]
fun i love he's playing clinton by the
way do you see that what they're doing
an fx movie kind of like the oj one
they're doing one on the quin uh clinton
lewinsky
clinton tarantino yeah
yeah but that looks [ __ ] good and
clive owen is playing clinton but that's
a weird choice it would never even cross
my mind i know it kind of worked though
i saw uh
great i love him in closer man oh
man that talked about a movie punching
you right in the taint i mean that was
like because every relationship you had
it all came up and the the cheating and
the the the wanting this girl and this
girl wants you but you want that one oh
my god amazing okay it was nominated in
2000 lost to american beauty that's what
i told you about
nominated but dude pacino and crowe are
great
it's a real like pacino showcase like he
just
he it puts his overacting
to use like when he's right
you know like yeah i'm just getting
warmed up like that type of [ __ ]
wow
yeah i still love son of a woman i still
can't res if it's on tv i'm gonna watch
it yeah yeah it's corny as [ __ ] but it
is it's like forrest gump where you're
like this is all ridiculous but i'm on
board i'm on board yeah it's it's also
the scene where he's tangling you're
like how do you can't i know i i love
pacino what can i say oh yeah totally
i'm a movie guy man [ __ ] i like him too
he's a legend god damn it god damn it
give me a wreck and go watch heat too
while you're at it if you want some 90s
action [ __ ] fun i didn't know this is
awesome man what this is the michael
mann movie it's it's i would say michael
mann's best movie
i put it ahead of heat come on ahead of
hate it's i think it's a i think it's a
masterpiece wow all right i gotta watch
it i've never seen it every scene is
it's different than he he does a lot of
action and he has a lot of like he does
great tense moments
but this is like all in the writing like
it's all dialogue it's all like it's
not the i don't think there's a spoiler
but it's like there's not really
violence in it there's just like the
lingering threat of violence interesting
and to me that's like kind of more
impressive to make like it's like a very
adult right it's almost like you don't
see the monster so it's scarier that
it's kind of like that
the monster is like big business
basically right like
trying to like ruin your life but uh man
it's [ __ ] killer yeah you know pacino
just kills it michael mann's a [ __ ]
beast i love him oh boy i love
collateral too collateral's underrated
underrated yeah michael mann's great
although ali [ __ ] the bid i walked out
on it what
only one of the only movies i've ever
walked out on wow i hated it and i loved
jamie foxx and will smith but i [ __ ]
hated the movie what didn't you like
about it i haven't seen it since it came
out so i don't remember it yeah a lot
yeah yeah no i saw in the theater that
was the last time i said wow i just
remember being like nothing's happening
it's boring it's not well i'm a big fan
of everyone involved i just didn't like
i couldn't take it i never walked out of
a movie oh i think might be one of the
only ones i've walked out on damn
that's wild if i paid for it i'm gonna
do it same with bad milk i'll drink it i
gotta get rid of it alcohol i can't let
it go alcohol i can't let it go yeah
i ate a piece of pizza at the stand
there was just a piece of pizza on the
table i ate it and i was like is that
yours i'm like somebody's wasting this
pizza i ate the pizza i probably got
delta
oh i'm glad i'm right next to you thanks
can you get it from a pizza i don't i
hope not
geez if that's true then [ __ ] little
italy's [ __ ] ah good point good how
about uh
give me a wreck
well if we're going uh we're going dudes
i'm going wreck road runner
i gotta watch it i mean i'm putting it
off i'm a documentary [ __ ] it's
talk about capturing the sadness you
feel like
it's heavy well it scares me because
it's like very close to home for us
traveling yes literally the guy who gets
to like the peak of where we could get
to and he kills himself yeah well if you
want you can just watch the first half
because it's all him making it he's a
he's a nobody heroin addict chain
smoking chef in manhattan skinny
kind of weird
earring you know that earring was rough
now here was rough sleeveless like he's
like a kind of a punk iggy pop type dude
and he's got a wife he's got a small
apartment and he sells his book and just
skyrocketed look [ __ ] rocked is it
good i loved it my girl's reading it now
she's like this book's amazing it's so
good it's uh
it's funny i mean it's ridden with so
much passion like he talks about cooking
and food like how we talk about comedy
yeah he talks about restaurants he's
cynical he i remember hearing him on
marin once talked about uh
how like the way like i think they made
the connection together that like
it's very similar to comedy being a cook
because line cook chef sous chef like
there's that pecking order like right mc
feature headline hierarchy yeah yeah
well he he worked his way to the top but
you can see him on a flip phone it's
like 1998 1999 and he's like what it's
number seventh on the best seller and
then it becomes best seller and then
people are like you want to do a tv show
and he's like with his wife going oh my
god this is overwhelming that shit's
fascinating the fact that they have
footage of this stuff is unreal i have
no footage of me as a as a young nobody
you know but they got footage he's in
the kitchen he's sword fighting with the
with the busboys you know he's just a
fun dude he was fun man fun guy but then
it gets just
let's travel i mean look i want to watch
the kobe one really badly but i know the
kobe one's gonna [ __ ] me up because i
love kobe yeah i just i'm just such a
fan like
of everything and i i know
like kobe has this imperfect legacy and
you know but i i loved him like it's one
of the things where like people talk
about michael jordan's impact but like i
was a baby when michael jordan was
drafted
you watched it all i watched i was 10
when he was drafted so i saw his whole
whole [ __ ] career yeah you grew up
with him i grew up with him
[Music]
let's try this other one
shall we please oh let me put this i'm
not a big rose fan i'm not going to lie
to you i don't love it but this is good
i'm just not a big rose guy i i'm not
good i'm not a big white wine or a rose
i'm a [ __ ] red wine drinker
yeah you too sally it's a white wine
fella but you're landing high falutin
just regular just give me wine yeah like
i buy the 11 jug and i'm just like get
the wine in me
that's not a good sign
what is this is just champagne i think
no this is chardonnay you said i thought
that's what it says there right
is it one of those yeah 100 chardonnay
it's got to be from this this sounds
pretty
champagne it smells pretty [ __ ] good
have you guys seen this sent it to you
what this trailer
this is
called la takedown
this is made by michael mann
before heat
is it good oh i think i sent this to you
during the pandemic i think oh no i
think we watched some of it at your
place i think it's like a sizzle to sell
heat
no this is a whole ass movie
a whole ass movie who's in it anyone we
know no it's a bunch of nobodies
and it's just no i know that guy though
shot for shot
of heat
oh no i don't know that guy maybe this
is like his
robert rodriguez yeah you know he needed
to make this to make that exactly i like
this better than the road
yeah look at that shot for shot
like the vaccine okay what we got here
is a heavy duty this is johnston and
johnson
yeah yeah then he was fizer
these guys are way better way better i'm
more of a chardonnay guy than than rosa
before
but uh
you know it's actually these actors are
like this director you get cast in this
movie with michael mann but then it's
like i hope they had good careers after
that because like you [ __ ] what are
the chances you work with michael mann
as an actor
the way there's so many good comics that
people have never heard of there's so
many good writers and actors oh there's
more
more
being an i was talking to soder about
this last night being an actor it's like
being uh that's why they're all nutty
because it's like being a hunter you
know or a forager like you just got to
go in and get it or not it's almost like
you shoot a bow at the deer an arrow and
the deer goes away you got to figure out
how to get the next deer the next meal
they audition apart they don't get it
that's it except before hunting the deer
they have to beg the deer to like them
yeah
yeah yeah exactly or blow the deer
please please
i like this one but this is way better i
will drink that that's [ __ ] good dude
this is really good this this tastes
like champagne i'll tell you our guy
good champagne really seems to care
white of whites i think back to school
is like my number one like when i'm
depressed movie oh yeah it actually is
great on rotten tomatoes it's like 86
really yeah it's a good one what's your
go-to depressed movie though i go ferris
bueller ooh that's good i love ferris
bueller i don't know why that that movie
just hits me right in my sphincter it
just resonates with me it's just fun
it's fun
i think broderick would like us i feel
like he we would get along with him yeah
he was a little depressed on uh
comedians come he's in custody i liked
him though he was funny too though he
was dry i like that but i feel like he's
like theatery which like could not may
not work to our advantage because we're
like a little more clubby and you know
but i i just love the elections like oh
man that's an underrated that might be
top ten comedies for me it's a as a dark
comedy that's not much better than
election yeah
but yeah road runner great you got to
see it it's good it's but is it going to
depress the [ __ ] out of me a little yeah
but you also hey you're living he's he's
died he killed himself with a daughter
but you're not and that's what you got
to take from it you gotta fight the
demons and push on
if you're dealing with that [ __ ] not to
get like serious at all but like please
get help because that's like you know
one thing that we lost the guy we look
up to but like do that when you have
kids just [ __ ]
crushes me i know the idea that i feel
selfish i dated someone whose father did
that and it was really yeah it was
[ __ ]
terrible it [ __ ] the kid up you must
think that
their life will be better without you
that's the only way you could do that
i don't think you're thinking rationally
in that moment
i don't think you're thinking about
other people in that moment i think
you're in horrible yeah of course i
don't think you're thinking about your
kid in that moment you know how he did
it no hung himself
sober
he was a booze bag he was a pill head
all that [ __ ] and he was sober
toxicology report clean which is even
crazier because that means he was like
i'm doing this
wow and hang is that's torturous
well it got weird but uh
i'm well hung but uh all right
i was watching this uh doc on spaulding
gray was also another like new yorker
genius intellectual yeah killed himself
jumped off the back of the staten island
ferry wow is that right yeah see that's
risky because you might just float
i think with he was he had intent so
it's like let me just go down with this
oh
it seems like instinct would kick in you
start i don't know yeah some people like
the people who jump off the you know
golden gate bridge and the second they
do it they regret it like the survivors
i mean
that movie about that yeah i mean that's
just the thing where i'm just like
i don't know man
that's
i think you're not thinking right in
that moment
yeah you get to a low point and you're
not mentally right i mean
i don't know that's [ __ ] dark yeah
wouldn't you love to be the save
wouldn't you look because there was the
movie the bridge
hell of a documentary they just pointed
a camera at the golden gate bridge for
like two years and got i think i don't
know 12 jumpers way more than that more
than that okay so one guy got up on the
railing was about to do it and this guy
just grabbed him and pulled him back and
the guy was like no let me do it he
pulled him in and then eventually the
guy was like thank you you saved my life
but would you love to be that guy
i would love to be the pull you in guy
really oh yeah you're a hero you saved a
guy's life what if the guy just jumps to
like a day later then you're kind of
like thanks thanks
but i stuck my neck out for you 24 24
suicide 24. damn and how long do they
point the the [ __ ] camera at that
thing what what a what a shitty director
by the way i got an idea and it's gonna
be real easy one year one year we can't
get our ideas made but they're like
suicides off a bridge
now we're talking yeah i like it we're
in there pitching comedy funny stuff ah
too fun how many how many deaths are
going to be in this right right how many
settings how many locations
can they be real people yeah i was just
pitching a comedy yeah good enough yeah
yeah
yeah they don't have to pay the the guys
who died that's a great gig for the
director yeah yeah
they gave them a day rape but they never
collected they never collected
that's great hello we're like get help
everyone and then we're laughing at
theirs
that's true well that's what we do right
i mean we our sincere selves and then we
have the way they're not their real subs
when they kill themselves we're not
maybe our real subs and we're making
[ __ ] up jokes
we're dealing with life right that's our
[ __ ] as i always say
[ __ ] you that joke's offensive apologize
for the joke sorry you didn't mean that
apology i didn't mean the joke either ah
suck all that jokes it's funny you know
we watched uh ted last night my
girlfriend i watched ted oh and i
remember
you remember we watched that in my hotel
room in vancouver
it was you me list gary veeder
carmen lynch forgot about that we were
all my hotel room in vancouver we did a
festival and we watched the movie ted oh
yeah great movie great great movie
the amount of politically incorrect
jokes are and it's just they're just
good jokes they're just funny jokes
like
it all you need it's funny that you need
like a bear a little stuffed bear to do
those jokes yeah for us to be like oh
it's okay yep
well he's a bear it's like but it's a
man voicing there that's how dumb people
are we need a bear to do this [ __ ] south
park is the perfect example of that i
mean it's uh horrifying [ __ ] but it's
their their little paper animations
nobody gives a [ __ ] have you gone back
to rick and morty yet i like it i like
it how many how many i'm three in are
you gonna keep going i'm gonna keep
going i'm gonna finish it it's [ __ ]
incredible dude yeah it's great
i like the
the grandpa he's he's the he's the best
he's the best character i love him man
but yeah uh
ted great i saw i was getting a lot of
[ __ ] for like doing dark humor for a
while and it kind of it gets to you
because you're like [ __ ] i don't wanna i
don't we don't wanna hurt anybody that's
not our intention we don't wanna offend
or whatever we just they're hurting
themselves like watch a [ __ ] clip of
my comedy if you come to the show i
don't do that many sets anymore i'm
mostly just doing the road i'll do like
a few sets a week in the city but like
i'm tired i'm on the road every week
sure so i mostly do the road so if you
don't watch the comedian you're seeing
then you're kind of an idiot i agree i
don't go to a movie blind i read a
couple things about it hey right yeah no
it's like going to show girls and being
like what is all this nudity i feel the
same way
like what is your deal but either way
i forgot my point
oh i do all these dark drifts i do it
all and it got to me like all these
people mad at me and yelling at me and
calling me or whatever and this and that
homophobe racism like
where are we getting all this but i saw
seth macfarlane on
bill maher one night randomly on the
road like flipping through it
he said the amount of death threats he
gets for family guy jokes was like i
don't know he gets like
8 000 a day or something and i was like
all right this is just part of it
i heard like 12 of them jumped off the
bridge
yeah but it sunk in like how much joy
has family guy brought the whole the
whole world people love that show as a
joke a second
they're not all great but some are
amazing and ted's great
and like the joy outweighs the and
you're sending someone a death threat
who's the who's the bad guy here you
want him dead
and he told a joke and you're the good
guy blow me oh dude and like the amount
of people that love that show i remember
i went to like a sixers basketball camp
in philly for like a week one year yeah
my parents just they were like just get
out of the city we don't want you around
wow and uh i went there and it was like
and
so we i go to basketball camp but it's
like me and like you know
two other white kids and like 50 black
kids in our bunk you know and there's
like one little tiny tv and we all
huddle around and we watch family yeah
the great unifier right and
everyone was laughing
every [ __ ] person was like oh [ __ ]
like it was like one of those things
you're like aw dude
so yeah yeah he's gonna get death
threats when you're that big but also
and you're irreverent but you're making
something [ __ ] awesome i know i know
chappelle said he got a like
this is the 90s so he got bags of hate
mail for this that tyrone bigsby with
the blind uh white supremacist classic
that's such a brilliant bit and you're
like how are you dumb enough to not get
i know i know i showed it to my mom
who's like
you know like obviously a very smart
woman but she's not like hip to comedy
she's like she's brilliant brilliant
brilliant yeah i mean she is hip to come
i should take that back my mom is very i
don't even know why i said that but you
know my point is that that has a range
of people that should like that but then
see to me you're more sane where you're
like that at bourdain doc that's gonna
that's gonna be tough that well because
because i love him that's like i loved
his work and i respect him like to me i
just know that i'll feel it
right you're gonna feel it
i'm a sensitive guy so i'm like if i'm
gonna watch that i'm gonna
i'm gonna be like [ __ ] i love that guy
yeah you know that's why it's tough for
me to watch the kobe one too sure like i
i
loved what they did and what they
represented and uh yeah yeah yeah but
the
the michael jackson thing when that i
never watched it i'm like i don't want
to see that i don't want to see him
touching kids and kids being sad and all
that
and then people kind of think i think
kobe and like bourdain had a bigger
impact on me than michael jackson i know
i'm just making the point like that but
you can watch that like i never watched
it you did yeah all right i wanted to
know what happened it's two kids that he
definitely was inappropriate i don't
need to see him allegedly
what do you think he was i think he did
too but would you let your kid sleep at
his [ __ ] place absolutely not that's
what i'm saying well there you go but
even if he wasn't like inappropriate you
don't let
i mean [ __ ] i wouldn't let him sleep but
invite a kid i won't let him sleep at
any celebrity's place maybe kevin spacey
all right
he just turns to the camera now you all
think i molested this child
but let me tell you real quick
i'm much more clever than that
uh it's always the i'm missing the cards
oh dude spacey's a killer one of the
only good netflix original series hmm
how many good mine hunter was good no
yeah that was queen's gambit was good
that was absolutely that was excellent
she lives in my building does she yeah
i don't know if that ruins my life with
uh my address but she lives in my
building yeah and it's not even a great
building it's not like this is great i
love doing that show that it was there's
stuff it was like it's one of those
shows where like you know where it's
going but it doesn't matter it was just
like a fun
distraction and it came out the perfect
time
we all just we all needed a feel-good
show during this [ __ ] [ __ ] storm does
it feel good i've never seen it you've
never seen queen's gambit i gotta get on
that oh it's it's [ __ ] good yeah
everybody loves shared experience we all
had as a country in a time when we
needed to be together yeah yeah it was
like a positive separated we needed
something to come together with and it
was like that and then
the tiger king
oh
tiger king was crazy loved tiger king
yeah that was fun
that's out there queen's gambit you
would like all right i'm shocked you
haven't watched that yeah i'm shocked
too i've seen everything else i'll get
on it it's good i think i tried rick and
morty first so i'll do that first all
right give me a peeve okay i got a
couple i don't know how long we've been
going oh and i got another recipe and
it's for you specifically
cause you're an oatmeal man i am a no
every morning with peanut butter i got a
[ __ ] better one for you oh boy
overnight oats huh you never do
overnight oats never heard of it i know
so
they you just put oats in a little like
put them in a mason jar
like one cup of uh oats one cup of like
milk
and then just throw whatever the [ __ ]
you want in there dude
you put peanut butter cinnamon for some
berries i throw some [ __ ]
blackberries in that [ __ ] oh that's good
blackberries are the most underrated
berry by the way i'm a razz man rasman i
go razz over black they're both good
they're both good but if i if but if
they're baldwins i'm alec is the [ __ ]
black but no let's be real alec is blue
really blueberry is number one
overexposed
fine so let's do this with the weigh-ins
brothers all right there you go there
you go that's a blackberry
that was just this show just turns into
taste buds
overnight oats you put it and you just
take it out in the morning like just
seal it off with a mason jar it's
amazing
wow interesting but that takes a little
planning what if we're drinking i'm not
gonna be thinking oh gotta get the oats
it takes [ __ ] three minutes before
you before you go to bed you put it and
then you open it it's less time than
oatmeal oatmeal i put it in quick oats
38 seconds better than oatmeal all right
i like oatmeal but this tastes better
and this is cold too yeah yeah i don't
want cold cold is good because i do hot
coffee in the morning so it offsets
i have
some variety okay
i don't know i like a hot oatmeal but
give it a try i'll try it i'll tell
anything it's gonna change your life
brother change my life i'll try it it's
good stuff
all right i gotta really sell it this is
up there with inside man i don't know
man
better than heat i like heat especially
in my oatmeal i think inside man is
better than i said insider is better
than that i'm sorry inside or inside
he's better than he all right i love
heat inside inside uh the insider is
better no better movie do do dis no i
like heat more okay oh
but i think i think he's great i think
he's a better movie insider great name
for a porn too
i mean that's just sitting there
but inside man insider
oh code i'll show you this
man is a gay porn
[Laughter]
uh
all right here's the peeve
this is asian restaurants that do this
it's mostly thai and chinese
they throw in like a
a secret hidden ghost pepper
oh that you guys you're so right i
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] i i'm having thai
yesterday i get a papaya salad i don't
know where i have a like a tiny pepper
in my mouth it's the hottest thing i've
ever eaten in my life yeah yeah how
about a little [ __ ] warning it ruins
the meal everyone's everything you're
done after that i'm chugging [ __ ]
milk yeah
right i know yeah
it's taking a load of my
remote
it's a milk grate challenge
it's a nightmare that [ __ ] hot pepper
it comes out of nowhere it ruins your
day you [ __ ] blood i i'm with you
and then you look like a [ __ ] on the
other oh and they're like what i ate it
too it wasn't you know it wasn't that
bad you're like no i got the pepper it's
awful general shows will do this and if
you're a [ __ ] rookie you'll eat one
of those black peppers but those will
[ __ ] you gotta you gotta take the
little tiny pieces yep because i love it
general so it's chicken oh yeah is that
your go-to chinese order no i'm a pepper
steak peppers i like the steak with the
bell pepper can't go wrong yeah i like
uh general sews it's too it's too
american it's a it's it's sweet it's
it's gooey that was a bunch of chinese
people going this isn't selling we got
to make it fatter and and sweeter and
the americans will buy it i love a
general service i mean i like it what's
the reason that and and and uh sesame
sesame the sesame's brother that's it
that's it just they sprinkle some spices
i think so right i remember going to a
fight with a friend when i was a kid and
i was like general shows is better he's
like sesame is better we are both
[ __ ] idiots it's coke and pepsi it is
the same [ __ ] wait go look up general so
who the [ __ ] is this guy orange chicken
is just i think like it's just it's the
same [ __ ] but like a slightly sweeter
maybe i don't know it's too much goo how
about um i like a little chicken with
garlic sauce actually oh
an egg roll when you're being nasty say
it again an egg roll oh yeah you dip it
in there and that's sweet and sour
how do you feel about cold sesame
noodles i'm into it yeah me too i grew
up on chinese i love that [ __ ] that
might be my favorite cuisine whoa i mean
all right
put thai over chinese tai might squeeze
in now just because we're getting damn
good thai yeah i have the childhood
comfort of same with the take out and
the to-go box and the [ __ ] little
carton come on it's tough i feel like
it's like kind of like movies without
sound that i grew up with but then
movies with sound came out and i'm like
i still like movies without sounds i
love buster keaton
yeah dude sherlock jr is playing at the
film forum we should go
yeah yeah
buster keane's the [ __ ] genius i mean
unbelievable that guy's unreally broke
his back doing a neck i think maybe
might have been both he would do his own
stunts yeah mr keaton's crazy he did his
own sense and he thought of them he
wrote it too like this guy is on another
level which is crazy because you could
just write out i'm not gonna maybe break
my neck
yeah yeah no he was incredible and and
universal by the way you can play him in
china and he'll he'll get laughs well
that's that's the genius of silent
movies yeah yeah chaplain too what do
you what do you got i got general so
here hmm
1812. he was a general he was very hefty
and he uh no yeah like what what's the
deal
i don't know they just like named after
him okay i didn't know if he made it
like colonel sanders
you know he was a colonel and he made
chicken
dude this is this [ __ ] this is great
i'm next level i think i'm just not a
rose guy me neither because this is [ __ ]
i i normally i'm not like white wine i'm
like it's fine i'll drink it but i like
red wine better but like this is [ __ ]
solid all right let me give you a peeve
hit me this thing has bothered me for
years i could never think of it when
when you asked and it happened to me
again and i wrote that [ __ ] down toot
sweet
i'm laying in bed you know i have
trouble sleeping much like you i'm not a
good sleeper awful i haven't slept all
weeks yeah i haven't slept all [ __ ]
week not once this week it's amazing
when you get a good night's sleep i feel
like i'm superman i'm on roids i feel so
energetic but uh i get no sleep and my
lady can [ __ ] go out like cosby
victim i mean it's just like a drop of a
hat i'm going to bed she's done she's in
there it's gone i'm like god you better
not cosby i know right
but uh she's gone she's out in two
seconds it's a gift if you have that at
home that's a gift it's like the people
don't get hung over you're like that's a
gift it's unreal yeah so i can't sleep
i'm laying in bed thinking about
childhood you know bedwetting my scary
dad whatever but
she'll wake up in the morning and nudge
me and go hey you sleeping
you ever have that hey you sleeping like
are you kidding if i was sleeping now
you woke me up so that's ruined and if
i'm not sleeping
you would know it so now you just ruined
the morning she's like you sleeping
are you you you up you sleeping i'm like
yeah i was you ruined it it's all over i
can't go back it's done i hate that
you're sleeping are you asleep what do
you mean am i asleep if i was asleep i
wouldn't answer you am i snuggled up
holding my teddy bear yeah i'm asleep
[ __ ] yes
was i snoring then yes i was asleep now
you woke me up so i gotta wake up answer
your question then the morning's ruined
yeah you're sleeping i'm real bad i get
anxiety i get this [ __ ] where like
you're going to bed even when i get my
anxiety in my heart's racing when i know
i've got six hours and i'm like [ __ ] if
i go to sleep right now i get six hours
so my heart starts racing then i'm like
[ __ ] five hours four hours yes and i
just don't sleep yes so this morning
this morning i shot up when the alarm
went off because i'm just i was awake
yeah so it's like it sucks i just wake
up like an hour before the alarm cause
i'm just like
i haven't slept all week because i had
to reroute my flight yeah from portland
because of the hurricane here which i
was telling mark i'm like dude you
should change your i have neurotic
parents so my dad is like you can't try
to land at laguardia there's a hurricane
all day and i'm looking at i'm like [ __ ]
there was a hurricane all day let me
call it delta
and i and i was land at midnight i would
have been fine and of course my dad's
like blaze i'm like first off i'm like
they have a better grasp of the weather
than you do yeah they're literally
dealing with jews
[Laughter]
we do control the weather yeah yeah but
uh
you know so i i cancelled my flight i
flew to la and then i so i lost it
another day wow that's another travel
day but i'm telling mark and marcus like
i'm gonna chance it and mark makes it
mark [ __ ] rolling the dice and coming
up with two sixes every [ __ ] time not
only did i make it i made it on time
with like a little bit early and it was
it was raining i mean that turbulence
was no joke no part of me like sam was
right i'm gonna die and we hit that
runway you ever have those fights where
you're like
it was one of those landings
and you know the whole the whole uh
plane went
you know and then we landed and i get
out and it's pouring rain and i was like
i'll never get an uber who's going to
drive in and i got an uber instantly
drove in the rain straight to from
newark right to the house i was home at
like noon on sunday damn yeah why i
definitely put a scared mark for a
second oh what the [ __ ] but no you text
me you land and i was like oh i was like
so jealousy man wait do we have to do an
ad yeah we should let's do an ad oh i
see matt uh grabbing his balls we might
be drunk is uh sponsored by better help
what's staying in the way of achieving
your goals figure it out with better
help uh better help with therapy for
21st century for the 21st century this
is not a crisis line this is not
self-help better help is professional
therapy all online it's all remote do it
from the comfort and privacy of your own
home flexible schedule phone or video
calls at your convenience get a good
match
they will put you with a licensed
therapist who's right for you i love
therapy i mean oh yeah therapy has
changed my life therapy's taught me that
you know my girlfriend says she's upset
with me to say i understand instead of
uh instead of okay then right right
instead of all right here we go oh is
that what you're supposed to do
it's fast when you sign up you can start
talking to your therapist in less than
48 hours no waiting around it's
affordable you don't have to be rich to
pay for this and financial aid is
available and now you can send messages
to your therapist anytime they'll go
back to you in between sessions don't
like your person if you want to switch
therapists you can do it anytime for
free they make it easy trust me it helps
to have someone outside your world to
talk to i believe that and that's true
it's easy to schedule affordable don't
take a load off your shoulders over a
million people have taken charge of
their mental health join them mark tell
them how to do it you got to get on it
better help is a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk
[Laughter]
we're 10 off your first month that's
visit betterhelp.com slash drunk for 10
off your first month h-e-l-p
dot com drunk for 10 off your first
month betterhelp.com drunk sign up for
better help to start living a happier
life and this is perfect because we
talked about the the bridge
so it all rolls together what an episode
yeah you got to give me a bit
oh
boy well i got a bit that i'm i'm
excited about but i'm worried that you
might have it oh [ __ ] so i want to i'll
be able to tell you if i do although i
don't know if i if you ever on the road
and the crowd yells out a bit for you to
do and you don't remember it oh yeah
totally
i'm like i don't [ __ ] know that joke
anymore yeah
do the white knight joke i don't know
what it is that's like a six minute bit
you know it's like an eight minute eight
minute bit that that's a lot of [ __ ]
remember it intricate parts and yeah and
if you get one part wrong although if
you do it i'll tell you this i did the
stupid again cause i want to see if i
could do it on the road the stupid
magician oh yeah yeah and and it killed
i i got it but i had to listen to it
like four or five years yeah
something let me just uh-huh here's why
i do this okay yeah and i'm listening to
it on the [ __ ] roof like it's not
like i'm listening to it in a club so
i'm like
he's right pause okay helicopter right
exactly but then you uh you know you get
into the rhythm of it you're like i got
it oh yeah no once you get it you're
just talking like yeah you forget it's a
bit and you're like oh this is like how
i tell it to a friend of the bar right
you get to that point where you get that
comfort where you're like this is how i
just talk exactly exactly all right so
my bit and tell me if this is too close
to something you have and we'll we'll
we'll knock it out but uh
something about your biological father
yeah it's a joke about how i'm jewish
and the self-serve
so uh
i'm doing this trying to do this whole
chunk about how technology keeps getting
better but people are getting worse you
know people are getting fatter but tvs
are getting thinner like technology is
beating us you know and like uh you're
talking to some guy
you meet a guy and you're like hey
where you from what do you do what's
your favorite color you got to do all
the [ __ ] and you're like man i wish
i could skip intro
you know technology's thought of all
these things and we're still doing this
[ __ ] you know and like you meet a
guy remember when you met a guy who
could speak three languages you're like
wow that's amazing but now i got google
translate so it's almost making us
shittier because we don't have to learn
as much we got you used to have a guy
who knew directions i know how to get
there take a ride on broadway take two
lefts and you're there now i got google
maps
i like that angle the first part is a
little similar you know that joke i have
where it's like uh where you like when
someone's telling you a boring story and
you wish you could just tap their face
like like it's a youtube video
thank god 20 seconds left
oh yeah so skip intro is a little
similar but i mean maybe it [ __ ]
works i don't know man i think i like
the idea of like
have three languages
say the last part again just like
you used to meet a guy who knew two
languages or whatever and you're like
damn this guy's a genius or whatever
this guy's so smart but now i i don't
have to learn them because i got google
translate i'm done
so the phone is no indirections means
nothing anymore that was a cool guy back
then remember i was like take a ride on
third take two lefts and you're there
you know and you're like wow this guy's
the man now there's a guy that gas
stayed for the cigarette just waiting
for someone to ask
just waiting for a guy the last man with
a flip phone to ask for directions right
right and any information some guy knew
is like this guy knows everything about
world war ii he's a buff now i'm a buff
because i can just pull it up
everybody's a buff everyone's a buff but
you used to it used to be like your
thing like i have a thing i know about
this right i i'm i'm that guy i'm the
guy who knows about
you know whatever uh civil war or or the
the moon lane or i know i think i know
everything about kennedy now there's a
million documentaries it's like you
don't really have to read or learn
there's a million ways to take in
information
but the phone is always if your
phone dies you plug it in it's back nana
dies that's it you know the phone it's a
joke
joke too oh okay my grandpa died i said
my grandpa was 89 my phone was brand new
i think it'd be cool if when your
grandpa died if you got an upgrade
you're like he's just like your grandpa
but he doesn't say the n word but that's
an upgrade
does he still say oriental they're like
yeah we couldn't fix everything that was
one of my jobs that was on conan that
was an oldie yeah that's an old bed of
mine all right well that's too similar
but
it's tough we [ __ ] we spend too much
time together so we started hacking each
other's bits what happened right right
well we just like whatever we not well
we do we you know what we're both jokey
so it's like
when you both do observational jokes
you're we've
we've both done this we're like has this
been done yeah and we've both been like
that's my bit yeah yeah well it's like
when you write that much together just
gonna happen and we mine everything like
you know how many times i've written the
thing about uh the the software update
and like your girlfriend's annoying
you're like oh tell me later and i'm
like oh that's a sam bit yeah but i've
thought of that like remind me later
yeah yeah the women who try to change
you that was an old bed of mine
like like women they try to change you
like
you know uh well how does it go again
it's my [ __ ] bed i can't remember
but it'd be like uh can i change you oh
no no uh
you know the the software update on your
phone remind me that's basically a
relationship yes women trying to change
you and you're like hey do you want to
do this they remind me later
that's basically dating that's a great
bit but that i've had that so many times
where the girl is is doing that [ __ ]
because that shit's real
it's real that [ __ ] is [ __ ] real yep
yep yep i'll ask you an etiquette
question please so i saw a comic he
posted a joke on his instagram today
and it was funny and the first comment
was from another comment comic who said
oh i've had this idea before oh but you
put it together he was complimenting him
but also insulting him
no i don't think i don't think it's an
insult i think it's a compliment yeah
cause he's saying like i've had the
thought but i couldn't make it a good
joke so i think it's actually a
compliment i think it's a compliment in
person but on instagram it reads
differently
that's a good point yeah like if you're
saying it to each other that's a
compliment
but like putting it out for everyone to
see is like oh this is a thought i've
had
that's that's i don't know that's a good
point yeah you're probably right i i
guess people said it to me at shows no
one's ever written it on my
post that i know so it's yeah that i
hear that but i think
putting that's the thing about comedy is
putting it together in a funny way is
the hard part like will ferrell is funny
but if you put him on stage with a
microphone i don't think he could
construct that construction is really
the hardest part of stand-up he could be
probably he could he would but he would
be like joe pera he would be like you
know he would be a character he'd be an
avant-garde right
so will ferrell's amazing amazing he's
not doing
like joke jokes like we're doing but
he's doing like he'd be doing something
unique in a way he would kill yeah
there's no way that will ferrell would
not kill at a [ __ ] comedy club he's
too funny but when you watch seinfeld do
some kind of thing about uh like you
know we all want to be home and then you
want to go out and then when you go out
you want to get home like that is so
much
uh like fine tuning in that bit it just
takes that takes so much repetition and
trial and error and tweaking and all
that [ __ ] but will ferrell see him at
any awards show when he goes up and just
murders like he knows how to construct
like i i disagree with that i don't know
i think he murders because the crowd is
pre-loaded to laugh at him and all he
has to do is give straight lines he's
not
he's just being a straight man and
everyone's laughing at his straight man
comedy
i gotta disagree i i think will ferrell
is not denying he's funny it makes me
laugh it makes those laugh here's what's
ginger about will ferrell he was trained
as a shakespearean actor really my point
like leslie nielsen yeah so he can be so
he's so serious that it's funny when he
gets mad he's like oh i wanna whatever
and you're like man that's so funny
cause is that true you're shakespeare
shakespearean that's why he's so good
because he's he's going over the top
serious which is actually funny it's
like uh glenn howard and from it's
always sunny who plays dennis uh-huh he
was like a juilliard actor oh there you
go so it's like when he goes that hard
you're like oh [ __ ] this is it's like
ted knight in in caddyshack he's going
all in he's the funniest one in the
movie i'm going to say a [ __ ] bold
statement i think tonight's the funniest
person to get oh yeah it's between
rodney and ted knight that's not even
bold i think you think ted knight's the
funniest i think he's easily the
funniest it's hard for me to go against
rodney ever rodney's number two don't
get me wrong but
but chevy and bill murray
by a mile in that movie
so uh i got nothing so all right all
right well i'll i gotta work that bit
around your bit so yeah just watch just
watch that conan says the last two jokes
okay i will when we're in the red
flannel matt over an
hour might oh we're well over yeah we'll
wrap up when it's happened on my joke
i'm trying to do my material man well
you're trying to shorten the episode
that people want to hear yeah
uh
no uh
that movie is [ __ ] classic that's
awesome that's a warm blanket movie yeah
for sure and they had fun making it too
what were we saying that oh i i was
watching an old uh rodney clip on carson
and he was talking about
being in caddyshack before it had come
out
and he was just like
moving and it was like almost his break
into movies he hadn't really been in
anything wasn't easy money before that
uh i think so i was like 81 82 but i
think this i don't know no caddyshack
was 70.
hold on did you hear the story about joe
pesci apparently like trying to bond
with dangerfield because he's a method
actor and he would be like you know
we're playing we're in this movie
together like we're playing kind of
scumbags let's go to the dog track and
dangerous like nah don't do that all
right
i think the whole thing was like he was
like you read your lines to me and you
and i'll read them back that's how it
works yeah and he just like started
stealing his lines that were funny oh
yeah caddyshack 80 easymoney83 all right
wow okay and then when was back to
school 85 or 86 yeah that was his first
like school is my favorite by a lot yeah
that just school's the funniest i don't
know if he did a good movie after that
uh me while he sparks his moments oh get
out of here it has moments but i'm
talking about a good movie uh
natural born killers
great movie is that a great movie yeah
it's a good movie
oliver stone and [ __ ] tarantino [ __ ]
you it's a good one well i like them
both but i mean anybody can put out
horseshit
you think it's horseshit ladybugs is
pretty good i'm not saying that at least
we know she's not two-faced she'd be
wearing another face all right you
couldn't make ladybugs now by the way
well it's a guy dressing up as a woman
it's just some gender [ __ ] tootsie
johanna man come on that's been done i
know i'm saying now you couldn't have we
watched tootsie recently that [ __ ] holds
up holds up
that's a great movie no one talks about
tootsie that is a good one murray
bill murray that's a playwright yeah
dustin hoffman is one of the best ever
unreal
he's unreal that's a that's a lovable
character yeah yeah i mean the graduate
and then like marathon man and then like
sleepers he does uh the [ __ ] he can
do it all he did i mean kramer versus
kramer
i've seen that movie like four times i
don't know why i [ __ ] cry every time
that movie breaks me
that ending with the french toast are
you [ __ ] kidding me
if you don't break at that scene you're
not you're made of stone that's brutal
man that's such a new york movie i love
very new york dustin hoffman man it's
fun everything about it like this when
that came out like crowds in a theater
live crying probably that's so crazy to
make a crowd cry it's probably like
getting a laugh for the director you
know okay i just want to tell you this
run right here
listen to this run
okay this is dustin hoffman
the graduate 67 midnight cowboys 69.
best picture uh straw dogs yep papillon
lenny
wow great all the presidents man these
are back to back now i think also best
picture uh marathon man wow straight
time seriously underrated this is a
great wreck
he's a small time criminal great wreck
straight time straight time
uh then a movie and then kramer vs
kramer tootsie death of a salesman then
he takes some time off does ishtar and
rain man i said death of a salesman on
broadway that's a festive picture again
rain man i saw death the salesman on
broadway guess who played uh the lead
brian [ __ ] dennehy whoa
wow murdered it dude wow it was
incredible interesting
why is that on broadway all the time
that should just be on loop on broadway
because it's just oh why isn't it yeah
you're right it's a classic yeah that
should just be like wick i see wicked
more than death of a salesman well
wicked's probably more do you ever see
the south park where it's like the whole
premise is like the
the the show wicked has subliminal
messages to get your wife to suck your
dick oh my god all the husbands just
take their wives to get blood
so they're all just getting their dick
sucked right after wickedness
like you gotta take her to wicked dude
it'd be nice you get a little it's a
little give and take
we don't want to see wicked come on i do
like musicals though i do too wicked
looks like [ __ ] though west side story
was my one of my favorite movies as a
kid oh dude tonight tonight
officer krupke he's got some of the best
jokes in comedy crap you yeah
yeah the whole joke the whole song's
about like bad parents and drug addicts
and alcoholics it's great west side
story is incredible and crownheim is a
[ __ ] genius genius those old jews man
i think that oppression like
i mean they were just like mel brooks
and carl reiner those guys were just
killing it back in the day good music
there's something like so satisfying to
get about a good musical because it's
like
not my go-to genre so if you crush it
you're pulling me in oh dude springtime
for hitler all that [ __ ] was amazing
producers is a [ __ ] cl zero mostel
that's a clinic
underrated movie two the front woody
allen with zero most stuff oh he he told
me about that and i watched it at my
house that's a good one no you didn't
watch it at my house no that was
somebody else dear mostell one of the
best yeah yeah estee at the comedy
seller bro she [ __ ] loves the
producers oh i'll take her to say she
dated everybody she had she she dated
zero mo still talk about self-esteem
issues hey your name's zero jesus christ
you couldn't name me one yeah
yeah fraction something yeah but i guess
it's all up from there my brother's name
was ten i'll tell you i got no respect
it is kind of a cool name though zero
zero maril
that's a good name well gilbert arenas
was an awesome basketball player he was
number zero his nickname was agent zero
and he goes i picked number zero because
that's how much time my my college coach
said i would get in the mba
[ __ ] you and he was a beast he was a
great player i mean i hate to say it but
a [ __ ] you is a good uh tool for
you know efficiency like anybody was
like i that guy said i'll never make it
or you're a piece of [ __ ] they all like
rose up well that's the ones we hear
about some people probably wear pieces
yeah
we hear about the legends the other ones
are [ __ ] just pieces of [ __ ] they
jumped off the bridge i'll tell you they
got no respect you know
it's all comes back to the bridge
all right let me tell you a joke idea
all right all right hit me so here's the
idea i had i had
so my girlfriend with someone she'll get
mad at me she'll be like
you know like i'll make a move on you
doing a movie and you never want to have
sex doing a movie and i'm like yeah i
don't have sex doing a movie i picked no
oh [ __ ] you're doing 13 going on 30. uh
i'm not gonna bang you during godfather
two all right you know what i mean right
so it's like you know
i want you to think about like i'm
trying to think of that like the turn
something about like uh
here's what you say after a great movie
wow we've never said that after i [ __ ]
you
i've never we never watched uh dog day
afternoon and went i'm so sorry right
right right also that's a great review
of a movie like the critics two thumbs
up or
i would have [ __ ] during that yeah
like that was so bad i would have i
would have rather [ __ ]
yeah there's something there though
that's funny yeah yeah
it's true though because when you're
wrapped in a movie you're in i mean i'm
very it's tough because women just take
their time with [ __ ] that's just the
truth is like whether it's like there's
a bathroom break they're like oh i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna go to the
kitchen for a second i'm like i'm
watching the movie and i want to start
it again yeah and once i'm in a movie i
don't like i've watched movies with matt
we're kind of just like zoned in you
know i've watched a movie with you we're
just kind of zoned in it's like
women are just different they can kind
of get up and like i'm gonna do this for
a minute i want to watch the movie all
right here's the turn
you want me to take a break from this
movie to [ __ ] you
what if i was [ __ ] you and then you
took a break to watch a movie good how
would you like that hold on
wait you're about to come let me go pop
in good fellas almost there almost there
yeah let's uh let's do let's try
let's try uh after hours she likes
scorsese right yeah yeah exactly
something there true yeah like when when
we're we're locked in we're locked in
you know it's the same with like i don't
know the guy who built the golden gate
bridge or the 16th chapel like this
episode's gonna be called the golden
gate bridge
but like michelangelo i'm sure he was a
horny guy he was probably like hold on
quit blowing me i got to finish this
pointing you know this the god's
touching the guy i got it i'll leave it
a complaint i like to complain is my
girlfriend wants to have sex with you
yeah that's a good point i'm i sound
like a real [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well i
will say this i just here's the thing i
love having sex with my girlfriend i
also love good movies uh-huh can i love
both you're a singer
and a pedophile
[Laughter]
here's the thing you love whatever movie
you grew up on my girlfriend's younger
than me
she's 13. and you know no 30.
going in 30. no she but like when
like she loves that movie 13 going on at
30. and like i'll watch it with her it's
fine it's like you know what it's not a
terrible rom-com i don't like it but i'm
like i get what i'm just saying like
these movies these cheesy-ass movies
this is a problem with having a younger
girlfriend
it was not as bad as i thought it would
be so you wanted to watch straw dogs or
dog day no wonder she doesn't like those
movies she likes she did like him she
was she fell asleep during dog day
because she was just dude we've been
traveling every week we're exhausted
okay so no she woke up and she's like
that was incredible i think she just she
missed like 15 20 minutes of it you know
but we watched uh and she loved insider
that's a pacino
she loved we watched tootsie she loved
tootsie i mean she she'll appreciate i
mean dude i'm showing her we watched
sunset boulevard watching classics i'm
i'm not okay
i'm an annoying movie guy well i'm like
we got to watch the classics too how
would she feel like if you tried to
break into sex during 10 things i hate
about you do you think she'd go for it
first off that's a solid movie
first off he's ledger [ __ ] rock so
let's not even that is a good move it's
taming of the shrew uh modern it's
shakespeare yeah yeah it's i mean that
movie is is solid i remember seeing that
movie in the theater it's how good heath
ledger is i remember seeing him reading
the theater being like that's a [ __ ]
movie star oh yeah when he sings to her
at the thing like that's that dude i
love you baby that's a good movie yeah
yeah that's a good movie yeah joseph
gordon-levitt
joseph gordon-levitt what happened to
that guy he's great i know larry miller
is in it he's good in it larry miller is
great always
one of the best actors one of the best
curb episodes oh the palestinian chicken
we're so in the same [ __ ] wavelength
it's scary
but yeah wait a minute
i'm still working on this bit here we
got to get back to the bit we're going
off
he's talking about his cell phone this
guy all right all right you got to make
a move
it's good it's good and it's hitting you
got to make a move during 13 going on
30. that's the that's the the test yeah
like is she willing to
take a break from the film also maybe
there's something to the older thing
like when a movie was on
nah that's not good he's gonna say like
when a movie's on tv it was on tv you
had to watch it like we grew up in the
cable era she grew up in the digital
arena dude
think about this
you watch tv now you watch netflix you
watch hulu you watch hbo whatever you
skip intro you you read the next episode
pause the next episode starts
immediately immediately i watched so i
was watching detroiters with her
and there's commercials because it's on
comedy central
so we're like oh [ __ ] so we're just
making small talk in between the
commercials
people used to talk more that's how
little we talk to people now yeah
there's a [ __ ] commercial and we're
like [ __ ] how do we fill this 90 seconds
get your phone out look at something
yeah totally but that's what has become
of us we've become so consumed by this
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think you answered your
own problem yeah sex during the
commercials
i'll tell you well there it is
90
[Laughter]
that's perfect that's a great bit yeah
sex during the commercial right get off
in 30. i'll tell you i can get up in 20.
come on the problem is it's that spca
commercial with the [ __ ] up dog you
know it's all cold you're like i will
remember you
you're like look at that [ __ ] yeah my
dick turned into a twinkie what the hell
uh
wait i gotta say this before we get out
of here i know we gotta wrap this thing
up but
i was on a united flight last week
leaving appleton in a hurricane coming
to new york i get on the flight i'm in
28 d i'm in the back of the plane
because i'm a piece of [ __ ] and
this gigantic buff hot french flight
attendant comes up to me and i got
status so i bored first so i'm sitting
there alone in the back of the plane he
goes oh my god i am a fan of we might be
drunk i love the show can i get a photo
and i'm like yeah sure i'm hungover it's
like six in the morning i'm like yeah
yeah the photo's gonna like oh post this
photo sir whatever you're doing this guy
was a hunk
super sexy guy and uh i i was sleeping
on the plane i passed out i took a
couple pills and passed out i wake up
this guy's got like beers on my tray
little green hulk little fentanyl but
he's popping beers on the tray cause
he's he's like oh you're a drunk you're
you might be drunk so he's putting out
he's giving me free beer he's loading me
up but i'm like dude it's six in the
morning i can't even look at this [ __ ]
right now he's gonna break every once in
a while i had a beer just to be like all
right i'll take it i want to be on brand
but uh no sleep this guy's just pouring
beard out my throat because he loves the
show so thank you sir i forgot your name
was like jean michelle or some [ __ ] john
growth yeah
the vaccine is [ __ ]
make sure to email us that we might be
drunk pod at gmail.com for the patreon
you know we're opening packages if you
send us gifts or alcohol whatever stuff
you want us to put up in the studio
that's at gotham studios on 38th street
look it up on google i don't know yeah
mark where are you going to be on the
road man i'm all over the road what does
this come out in 2018 what is this
oh great all right i'm in uh
arlington virginia right now i mean
arlington texas right now jesus big
difference yeah big diff texas come on
out uh
nashville portland madison wisconsin
atlanta oh my god new orleans yeah i got
some hot dates coming up check the
marknormancomedy.com
grindr yeah i'm all over the road praise
all uh taliban i got left boston this
weekend i got on there too later oh dude
six shows hopefully we had a seventh
let's keep [ __ ] rocking i can't wait
we've added two already let's keep this
party [ __ ] rocking september 2nd
through 4th boston we got uh we got
millersville pennsylvania the 15th we
got helium and philly september 16th
through 19th we got moon tower in austin
i'm doing a bunch of like one-man shows
[ __ ] i mean i'm doing my headline
you said i don't know why i said a
one-man show st louis indy springfield
[ __ ] chicago illinois oh samurail.com
i love that place uh great check out you
got a thing coming out soon dude sally
and i have a project we've been working
on norman's in it it's gonna be great
everybody's there we're basically
working on a project that's about like
the comedy club's opening up again in
new york city during the pandemic it's
called full capacity or 100 capacity
either we'll decide on one of them but
uh i like full
i like full too i think we'll go full
capacity but we got uh you know
amazing comics and marx in it uh
colin quinn
romano ray romano
sam j taylor tomlinson ronnie chang
[Music]
from snl uh we got we got a squad of
people in it uh it's gonna be great
you're gonna love it
and uh it comes out
early september and it's going to be
killer all right it's a feel-good piece
about coming back from the pandemic
similar to what we did with up on the
roof but it's much more conversational
with comics you're going to love it
can't wait to show it to me on my
youtube hell yeah i'll tell you you're
right you guys are taking over i'm at
the stress factory in new jersey oh i
forgot that but yeah that's going to be
hot when you're stretch factory uh
next weekend not this weekend but the
one after so we just had a classic
weekend man oh i love it it's friday
saturday we love your
great club great town new brunswick uh
and i got a netflix coming out but
that's in november but yeah who knows
we'll see what happens so yeah
keep drinking join the patreon tell a
friend see us live send us an
email uh
and give him hell out there keep
drinking comedy
[Music]
[Music]
you